today's episode is brought to you by
bridge
credit solutions the number one stop
for money back guaranteed credit repair
go to bridge credit solutions dot com
slash theo today's guest is
the um subject of a new
documentary which really is a
just kind of a scavenger hunt into into
this man
and his journey with wrestling and
everything addiction life everything
life
life today's guest is
mr david arquette
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]
he came in recently and he just sent
those over as a gift it was pretty nice
of him
oh yeah we're pretty happy to have him
look what somebody made
on a 3d printer yes on a 3d printer
david that's so dope
pretty nice huh
you have uh you have quite a collection
of
yeah you can get into there um and we
shut that door do you mind there
oh sorry no you're good actually it was
your fault but um
do you have you have quite a collection
of things that people have made for you
i saw in the documentary
yeah i got a bunch of collection i've
been collecting since i
started making money at 17. but just
isn't it funny when somebody makes
something for like isn't it
yeah i almost feel like you can't show
the appreciation that things really
deserve sometimes
yeah totally yeah it's cool to
it's cool with somebody i love art in
general and when somebody puts their
artistic
ability to like do something with you
involved it's always
dope it's like i don't know it's
amazing especially when it's fans and
all this stuff yeah it's crazy you have
a you had a marionette somebody made
like a um
yeah you have the marionette you i mean
just briefly in the documentary you're
able to see
different little they didn't they don't
focus on it
but they have this little thing you see
a little doodad or a piece of art here
yeah yeah you know yeah you really get
led into my world so you see a lot of
sort of my house
and my some of my stuff i collect i like
collect giant things i have a giant
chair in it a giant
like tennis racket oh yeah weird stuff
like that
do you sometimes i just started drinking
diet coke
yeah i drink diet stuff too i feel like
an old person when i drink it do you
i guess so yeah i mean
you know it's better than all that sugar
though there's these really great ones
called the united states of soda that
just came out
and i'm only saying it because i just
fell in love with it it's a
just 30 grams of sugar like
not sure grams of sugar 30 calories
total
oh yeah so it's like just a little teeny
but it it tastes good it's better than
uh lacroix or whatever i like licorice
and you could burn 30 calories you could
bend over and pick something up and burn
third half you know that's 15 calories
right there yeah
i often ran into you at the at the gym
before
yeah and now i got my my mini theo
vaughn working now you're coming in and
you do have a little bit of flare
growing huh yeah
yeah you know flying brian pillman jr
yeah or bulletproof brian pillman was
really my
inspiration diamond dallas page had
always had a great
mullet yeah yeah they got a lot of good
mullets i'm trying to think of something
they had back and they even had haircuts
that were
who was some early mullet work that they
had in wrestling
old school shawn michaels yeah yeah they
had some wild haircuts
i'm trying to think if hacksaw jim
duggan made his was just kind of
such a funny guy yeah his wife debbie is
so nice
yeah they were at legends of wrestling
the last match at the
at in the documentary yeah they're
really
great people you meet the you meet these
wrestlers and a lot of the time like ric
flair is incredible too but his wife
wendy's like the
sort of boss behind all these guys you
know what like my wife christina's the
boss behind me
she's responsible for producing this
whole film and
dealing with all the crap that came
along with it
yeah so it oh there he is right there
yeah
oh yeah my god man he looks like he
would use that board on like a
standardized test honestly
it's so funny he walks around with the
board still
really yeah people get it signed and
everything oh that's awesome man yeah
his whole thing was amazing yeah man
that was a wonderful time that was a
time when big boss man that's a time
when i grew up in that
when you had real i don't know i guess
that's when i was a kid too so that's
when i saw it
you know it was like headlights looking
right at me of just excitement and
staying up late at night at
10 30 to see uh saturday night sometimes
on saturday night yeah they would have a
championship bout
yeah yeah they well it was all this it
was something they set up it was like
these were really weird matches
saturday night main event yes and then
it would just be like these quick i
don't think like any real
belts were ever exchanged it wasn't a
typical kind of
fight it was more like a spectator thing
yeah
yeah it was wild man i remember just so
excited and
sometimes i'd pass out because the
excitement i remember just waking up in
the morning and didn't know what had
happened and my brother was gone and
yeah no internet back then you couldn't
catch up no you had to find a friend
your internet
was the first friend you saw at the bus
stop or whatever and you'd be like
what happened larry like i got ground
and you're like
this [ __ ] internet sucks you're like
this dude is dial up man i need a real
friend
who has facts yeah that's what's also
cool about wrestling it's like
i have a couple friends brent joseph and
curtis reynolds who
have just been my friends for years but
they're friends that love wrestling too
so we all like
it's almost like those kids again
growing up
you can call up and talk to them that's
what i love about rjcity too my tag team
partner
we can talk wrestling and he's all he's
wrestled half of these guys so he can
tell you stories about
hacks on jim duncan or you know
piper or whatever good tales yeah you
know the closest thing i've seen a
wrestling in a while in real life is we
nick do you have that uh bring up that
park thing in portland the other day
this a
t i don't know if you saw this or not
this is
um okay are you
familiar with rj city at all i'm not i
saw him he's
hilarious he's really funny on instagram
is he
i mean twitter yeah he's a real twitter
he's a real
millennial i'll have to check him out
this is protesters in a park but
this to me seemed like i mean look at
this
yeah to me i know like a lot of these
people like
you know a lot of this is political
stuff but a lot of it to me has a very
it starts to get a very wrestling type
vibe um do you see
any of that when you see some of these
park battles these days it seems like a
lot of
costuming you know what the best thing
i've
seen on the internet it just came up
this morning on reddit it was
otter gangs fighting each other and
seeming for
yeah these gangs of otters are getting
together and they're fighting each other
in singapore
oh water animals you mean otters yeah
the otters
that reminded me of wrestling oh look at
this
this is so fun look at these otters
oh hell yeah so they're like these
otters that are just wild otters
but there's gangs of them and they don't
like the other gang
damn really and they're like they're
having a rumble here
these honors just oh [ __ ] they're going
to add it look at the small crew
they're smaller than the the big crew
and they're going for it
this is the blm royal rumble oh my god
look at this guy that came out the top
rope you saw this guy
no i know they're really into it and do
they know who these otters are are they
pets or that people brought or these are
just
these are no natural no they they like
i think they might have bred the otters
for this lake but then they
they broke up into two different groups
and then they don't like each other
man it's kind of like romeo and juliet
but like gangnam style yeah and that's
in asia
yep wow west side story oh they won't do
that dude
they'll fight anything i wonder if
michael vicks behind this i feel like
that's crazy dude how how how crazy do
you think if michael vick would have
fought a cute animal against each other
i wonder if it would have been different
oh man like gerbil or you know like i
guess probably not because
they had it was i think they got upset
because of like a lot of the deaths of
the animals but
anyway um yeah so my friends the cop
who's in the
documentary jerry in connecticut he just
sent me a video too of these two
uh turkeys fighting and fighting for a
girl
that's something funny about animals
fighting over a girl was just so funny
and i guess we do it yeah i guess
animals will get real territorial
yeah you know did you ever get in a
fight for a girl whenever you were
younger you think yeah for sure i once
got upset i dated alyssa milano for a
little while and i once got
upset she showed up at this club we all
go to roxbury
and she showed up with another dude and
we were just broken up and i was like
crushed did you stay in the club no i
came outside i
kicked her car unfortunately i
apologized to her
since she's she's cool i was a real
piece of work but i i just kicked this
out of her car
we got to do that bad but we didn't even
really fight it was so pathetic
were you pretty heartbroken or not you
think oh
yeah she was like one of my like first
lovers
i mean yeah she's a wonderful girl
dude you had a real nice smile huh yeah
but were you all i mean you were pretty
handsome i mean you're still a handsome
guy
oh thank you but i mean this is a time
in our lives when people really were
that was just young young in in
hollywood for the first time never
really had
pictures taken on me
i was a mess though i'd once like
confess my love
i hope she doesn't mind me sharing all
this but uh
once confessor love and i had taken some
pill and then
oh we had some real sweet conversation
and i'd forgotten
all about it but she was so hurt i
don't blame her i was a real like
horrible boyfriend
there was terrible things that happened
oh we once went on this really beautiful
trip
oh i feel so i mean
at least you're honest about being a bad
boyfriend i was a really bad boyfriend
oh man we went on this trip and we
were playing this mixtape and it was all
these beautiful love songs and then
she popped it out and she saw some girls
writing on it and she was like where'd
you get this
tape and i was like oh for my old
girlfriend
she's like how dare you i didn't get it
at the time i totally get it now
but yeah yeah it's been a long road
to figure out how to be a good man
that's been
something for me oh yeah i feel that man
i feed dude that's what this whole
podcast is based on
oh dude struggling
bro you're a young guy you got a serious
lady or no i've never had a serious lady
in my life no no kitty i don't think so
i mean i have
yeah i've just never been in a
relationship where i didn't lie or cheat
you know that
that's kind of really i think been my mo
you know kind of i've always like
i think like dude i remember having a
paw
some girl invited me to colorado one
time i go she takes me to a party
i'm at the party somehow i end up
getting her to play like a board game at
a new tick a long time
and then i met some snuck offs with some
other girl and like professed my love to
some girl in this closet and
yeah i don't know everybody's feelings
got hurt yeah
i hear you my first marriage i i was
really
faithful with everything and you know
it's you know it's one way or another at
all
i don't know there was a lot of stuff
that happened
i got my heart broken i don't know
i don't it's it's important to be
faithful and you know true it's hard
though
it is hard you know especially when you
have a broken heart
and uh you got animosity and like
for like when you lose faith and love
yeah you know
sometimes i think i lost faith in love
like before i even knew what love was
you know
yeah totally yeah totally i mean i'm
still
trying to figure out everything marriage
and family and all that stuff
well you got a beautiful group over
there you got that little fella that
high-fived in the documentary yeah
charlie and gus there's 63. i'm an
incredible wife christina
who's been amazing and really taught me
a lot about
loving myself and you know that's really
what it all comes down to like i've been
on this whole quest to like
you know find love and all this stuff
and as cliche as it is that people say
you have to
you have all these things at least i
have all these feelings that
i'm like you know i don't know does
she love me or does you know certain
things happen during the
whole thing of this movie which were
pretty intense just
yeah there's me like yeah her being
really upset with me like
do you want just want to die like is
that what you want to do
and i had to sort of come to terms with
that like i don't want to die
but i wasn't happy either so i had to
figure out how to love myself
as crazy as that sounds like do you do
what were some things you feel like
cause like i mean i go to
you know i'm in recovery so i go to like
stuff like that you know that's good
yeah that stuff helps you so that stuff
helps um
it's good to have like a group that kind
of helps me yeah for sure
it's hard for me to not be like i got my
biggest thing is just with my mom i go
through moments where it's just like
there's no point in like being upset
anymore it's almost like my brain like
like sometimes i feel like she was mean
to me when i was really little before i
even knew
i was alive or anything you know right i
can't go back and fight those wars i
don't even know if it really happened
right sometimes i think i'm just over
extremely overly sensitive you know
yeah and then you grow up in a world
where it's like
you got to be a tougher you got to be
able to you know put a rear naked choke
on somebody or something you know
like you know and then it gets scary and
then
now i'm a little older it's like okay at
least i can try to figure out who i am a
little bit and not
be scared at least to do that yeah for a
while i was trying scared to even kind
of figure out what i was feeling or
anything you know
yeah completely it gets interesting so
the
the
doc i watched the documentary last night
i didn't watch the last 20 minutes
because i didn't
want to ask you about anything that
would give it away
um so it's it's a documentary it's a
mockumentary there were parts where i
didn't kind of know like it's
it seems like a little bit of i don't
know you tell me
it's a documentary okay i didn't like
they kind of set it up so i'd start from
the bottom and go up but like
even there's a death match in it that
wasn't planned they weren't even
supposed to be filming that night
it's something i set up i'm the one who
also went on all the independent circuit
the film crew didn't really follow me on
all that
i loved that yeah it was really fun it
was a
real uh education yeah when you get to
places like there's a moment in the
documentary you get to the place
and uh well here's a question right here
that came in from a young fella for you
oh nice
this is all real-time stuff no no no no
no no this is real time so
this is all we'll be edited later but
these were sent picked up this week
since we're david arquette why in the
goddamn [ __ ]
would you wrestle nick gage in a death
match
what's the point you could wrestle so
many other indie stars but why would you
choose someone
that is willing to stab you to death
with a light tube
get back at me good good question good
question
i should have asked myself that before i
did it
what happened was i was supposed to
wrestle joey janella who's an incredible
wrestler
the spring before that but i couldn't
because i got injured or i was doing a
movie or something
so then they were doing another spring
break the next year in los
angeles and i uh
and the wrestler was wrestling the gage
fell out and
he said you want to wrestle the cage and
i didn't even really know who he was and
didn't know much about like death
matches
i knew about hardcore matches uh
i knew certain things but i didn't know
that there was
death matches are kind of frowned upon
by some professional wrestlers because
they call it garbage wrestling
kind of came from i don't know if it
came from backyard wrestling it
they have a whole world of it and oh
yeah mexico and then
tetanus shot wrestling we used to call
it no game yeah yeah yeah
circuit yeah yeah i actually asked
somebody
before that because my wife was all
concerned she's like uh
freaking watch do you um do you know if
they anyone has like you know what you
may call it
first aid kit no no like have been
tested for like hepatitis or something
and i was like i don't know do you ask
somebody
hepatitis is a black wrestler that i
know that's probably one of the best
wrestler names ever
no kidding that's hilarious yeah so i
didn't know
like if i was supposed to ask i didn't
know i was in over my head
you know and it sounds like you've been
over your head you were
born yeah i have been i really am trying
to figure this all out but i went and i
uh i did a bunch of research on
on death matches and everything i still
didn't
know what i was getting into so but to
answer the question i wanted to
that's a segment of wrestling that has a
really
strong fan base that really love
wrestling and
even though a lot of people's frown on
it a lot of people love it
so it is something i we wanted to do a
backyard wrestling match we wanted to do
like a hardcore match
but it just didn't know how hardcore it
was gonna get
and is that the one that's not the one
that i see in the documentary though
yeah that is
okay because that really yeah that was
definitely
you could see somebody's eating fritos
right by the ring that's real [ __ ]
it was real i was like getting spit on
people i hated me
but the idea was like if i could win
over this crowd i could win over
uh any wrestling yeah yeah it seemed
like it must have been pretty brave to
wander first of all it's scary going
into somebody else's backyard that's
always a scary thing
that was really like okay let's do this
know
like i just can't i just
i don't know i equate this whole film
this whole experience to like almost
cleaning out your garage or like any
kind of task like that
where it seems so big and insurmountable
but then once you get in
you just work on one corner then finally
you'll clean up the whole place
and that's sort of you just have to keep
it keep going like in wrestling
if you hurt your neck don't worry
because next week your back is going to
hurt way worse
you know what i mean you keep trading
these injuries all along the road it
just never stops
yeah it's almost like you're a voodoo
doll but you keep doing it to yourself
in a weird way
that's true it's true i was thinking
about doing a little video game of
because my son used to play this video
game of a little voodoo doll
and i wanted to do one of me where then
you could get anything
try to blow me up or hurt me and i'd
just come all back together
and he's like you you can't kill david
arquette yeah that's crazy
um when you're doing the uh
when you're doing the documentary so at
the beginning you talk about
you won the wcw championship
yeah and at that time were you
like were you still like running real
hot on the hollywood stuff were you
wanting to try to do something different
you also seem like kind of a loner that
kind of likes to do their own thing in
in a way to me was that part of it like
if you look back on like kind of
learning about who you are based on some
of your life path and the choices you
make
dick are you able to like kind of see
why you chose that or do you have any
thoughts about that
yeah in the movie it like kind of sets
it up like
you know screamed kind of typecast me as
a goofball
and doing wrestling was kind of like bad
for my career
i don't really agree with that
necessarily that's
my wife kicked me out of the editing
room at one point because i was like
no you can't say that that's such a rule
you gotta because i say in one point i
haven't
you know gotten a job in in 10 years
like who goes to
yeah who goes to auditions over and over
again that hasn't gotten a job in 10
years
but what i say right after that is i
haven't gotten a job from an audition in
10 years
i've i've worked within that 10 years
it's just
you know people knowing me or or just
word of mouth or whatever
so it's a little like confusing but
the you know i've always like made these
weird choices
you know i i'm very public with stuff i
called into howard sterling had a bunch
of drunken conversations and
did a bunch of att commercials those are
probably the things that hurt my career
more than anything
honestly than than the wrestling film or
wrestling in general
so i don't really agree with that but my
my career was at a weird place
ready to you know when you get up to a
certain place where you're doing
your own films it's kind of like if this
next one doesn't do
great then you kind of fall back down on
this ladder of
success but if you could parlay it and
have your films
continue to do good or just even make
money
then it's a you know you can kind of
keep going with it
but and but having any of those
expectations are it's almost unrealistic
a lot of it's out of
a lot of it is out of your control yeah
totally unless you do it yourself and
that's what i've sort of learned that's
why we did this documentary it's kind of
taking
control of your life and your career or
just your
what you want to put out there yeah it's
what you've done with this this podcast
it's that kind of attitude where you're
like [ __ ] it
i'm gonna you know do what i want
structure it the way i want
you know and then that just builds on
then you can do other things that you
want
different projects start popping up then
you start spending your energy on your
own stuff
yeah rather than waiting around for
someone to you know stamp you cool or
not
yeah so that's just not the way to go
anymore and people can do it with their
phones and learning
editing on on their on their phones or
on a computer
you know it's wide open now because
storytelling is getting better
people are more aware of filmmaking and
and what it takes to tell a good story
so you can read books on it you can look
at youtube videos to learn
things about lighting like there's all
kinds of resources now
yeah you know it's funny when i was
watching it one thing i started to
realize
was because i'd seen you we did just
cross paths at the gym a couple times
you know and uh you were always playing
were you a trainer or racket what were
you guys doing
i was always just going i usually play
basketball and then do
some weights that's usually just what i
do to get cardio i thought maybe
i am a sweater are you i'm yeah i sweat
too much it's gross
dude my legs i'd get these uh i
shouldn't probably say this but
i'll get these in india i used to get
these erection pills from india right
yeah and then they may not look so
sweaty no kidding
why didn't you just get them like legit
they're too expensive
and they just they're too strong man
though
strong oh wow god bro i couldn't even
bend my arms i was like a damn
gingerbread man trying to have snacks
no but these men they would make my legs
sweat so bad and mostly on the back of
my legs so it was just
oh so i have to keep my back and my body
away from a woman during like any sort
of like
you know sensual engagement and damn it
just broke me man it just
god but they were so cheap and they were
they were
they would give you kind of a d an
erection but a soft like a co
like a manageable erection manageable
because the stuff that these selling
farm a big farmer that dick that big
farm is selling is too much
it's too heavy yeah um but what i was
going to say was when i watched the
documentary one thing i started to do
was
that i did notice i liked the story and
i liked the references to wrestling you
know because i i like wrestling myself
um but i love i started to care about
you though as a person as i'm watching
it you know
i start to get invested in okay
obviously i know who david arquette is
but you know i just started to
the scene that really got me was with
the scene when you're doing the uh the
street fighting with the mexican guy
oh yeah man that was amazing i didn't
even know street
like wrestling was a thing it really put
me on your side it put me on your side
like in a
you know i'm already on your team as i'm
watching it but it put me on your side
as like in a
just in like a real human kind of way i
feel like um
so i know you're not asking about that
but i'm just trying to give you just how
i felt about
during the documentary um now there's
some wrestling
in our circuit there's some you know
there's some hot air balloons out there
and i want you to take a peek at this
guy right here tom shiguro
oh yeah and he had this wrestling uh
this promo video that came out a while
back uh
just about a month ago
yeah you've also said quote they have
diminished capacity
yeah could you explain what you meant by
that exactly and would you like to take
this moment to apologize
oh no i was i meant that they're stupid
uh they're poor
um they're all beneath me uh
you know they're losers if they want to
come you know maybe clean up my toilet
or whatever
i could spit on them while they're doing
it give them a little taste of the
mystique
hey rick you're so strong you could even
withstand the ankle lock
oh it's true it's damn true mr greg what
about the uh wrestlers themselves some
of them
have reached out to you saying they used
to be fans of yours
how they've been hurt by your remarks
how do you respond to that
mission accomplished get it mr grinch
this is my parrot solstice you know we
always enter the brain together
anybody wants to get the turkey slicer
come come at me man
mr rick you are never down for the count
you are the best there is the best it
was and the best i ever will be
just keep those jeans high and tight and
know that you are the excellence of
execution in everything you do
you think you can do what they do
wrestlers
yeah it's fake why can't i win a fake
fight sign me up
let's rehearse and then i'll whoop your
fake ass
that's what burns me what that's what
burned me that part
oh yeah did you guys have it out
yeah i went back at him but that just
it's it's fake
it's it's it's it's it's not graphed
it's organized
but it's not fake at all once you get in
the ring you'd
be surprised how not fake how real it is
and uh you often like people here
waiting to kind of teach you a lesson
once in a while because you're bleeding
in the documentary yeah
that was a death match though but even
the backyard match but
you almost there's always something it
just hurts to take those bumps and i had
three fractured ribs when i had to
wrestle rj city and a bunch of stuff
oh man it's a good look with you as a
wrestler
oh i came back at him this is me coming
back mystic and i went more old school
style
oh yeah buddy here waiting for the rack
i mean obviously it's got no respect for
the business that thompson
rat king a lot of smack being thrown
around by mystic rick saying wrestling
is fake
what are your thoughts on that oh
was it fake when i nabbed the gab
out of that little russian hunter mr
michael rappaport
was it fake when i broke the spirit of
that little norwegian smut mannequin
mr crystal
was that fake rick was it fake
when i put the dirty you noggie on
little bobby miyagi
was that fake ricky
the only thing not real here is you
brother yeah you little diet denier
starch addict gout candidate i bet you
can't even skateboard
that was the personal like that's a
because that's the part that hit me i
think there's a certain element of
people out there that don't understand
when they call it fake how it hits some
people
yeah that's for sure where does that hit
you when they call it fake
oh man you just don't understand how
real it is until you get in there
it really is like it's getting crazier
and crazier not that it's
there's a there's a real beauty like i
wrestle cult cabanas
one of my favorite matches and ethan
page these guys are
super pro so even though they're making
it real
it's uh it still isn't as painful as
some of those
other lessons people teach you you think
you could beat the fat guy that was in
the beginning of this it's a girl yeah
come on you think he has what it takes
actually once it gets once he gets into
the ring do you think he could
i mean has he trained probably that's
the thing like
wrestling anyone would go on a very
short limb and say no he is not
well then it's just it's kind of like
something you usually
shouldn't do like unless somebody's
really training because
every wrestling match is as good as
the most experienced person in there you
know or the most
you know spec like the most trained you
know they don't have to have the most
experience but
someone who really gets it can make you
look good one of my best matches was
with jack perry
and jungle boy aw and he's just so
talented that he
made him made me look like i could do
things that nobody had ever
i'd never tried before a canadian
destroyer and the only reason it works
so well is because he's
so great at it i mean it's certain
things you're not really supposed to
talk about or whatever but
right but he's a super talented wrestler
luke perry's son oh is it really yeah
god dang he's damn beautiful dude yeah
he's great he's a movie star this kid
he's
never smoked never drank he's got a
great head on his shoulder he's tough as
nails
he's better looking about easily sixty
percent of the women i've dated
the easily problem even the guy above
him right there
yeah lucha soros he's an amazing
wrestler wow he's
good you know i don't know six eight six
ten
so you really have a love for this whole
world i guess that's something when i
got
as i'm going through um you cannot kill
david arquette
that i'm like okay is this love is this
a real passion that he has for this
yeah i love wrestling i've always loved
wrestling just sort of i've always loved
it as a fan
yeah kind of like and then when the
championship thing came
i was promoting ready to rumble they
said we'll
put the belt on you if you can stay till
the next pay-per-view
i thought it was a terrible idea but
diamond i was saying
paige broke it down he's like listen
well you don't have to do it if you
don't do it then the promotion already
rumbles
over the whole ready to rumble things
over you won't be wrestling with us
but if you do you'll stay with us you'll
travel with us you'll go
you know do a pay-per-view and that's
kind of what i really wanted i thought
it would be really fun
and i thought it would be taken more as
a funny storyline rather than something
so serious and kind of
devalued the belt which i understand now
what was more d
what do you feel like was more devaluing
the fans that were saying this is
uh you know using a guy from hollywood
if you will
um or
critics that were saying this is not
what somebody like david arquette should
be doing
yeah i mean i think part of it was i was
an actor i was smaller than
most of the wrestlers back in that time
period
since then you've had smaller champions
like daniel bryan and
mike mazzanin yeah and uh
i forgot seth rollins sort of some
some guys so rey mysterio is like kind
of the first yeah rey mysterio yeah
hell henry rollins could win a belt i
think if you gave him he's pretty tough
i was a tough guy
but yeah i don't know it was just sort
of that i was an
actor and i wasn't trained and they just
didn't accept it as like this
in funny thing and then guys like booker
t had never been the champion or scott
steiner so
i was uh i asked booker t in the locker
room i said how many times have you been
the champ booker and he's like never
so i was like oh [ __ ] so then when i
went out next i
i went off script and i said i don't
deserve to be the champ booker t
deserves to be champ
and he was the champ a few uh like two
you know the belt went to jeff jared and
then i think it went to booker after
that so not that i had anything to do
with it but
it's good to plant those seeds yeah did
you um
so did it did it get weird because then
after you get the strap you
did you start to feel ashamed of having
it are you like holy [ __ ] you go from
excitement to then all of a sudden i
still have this thing
and i have you have to carry it you have
to carry it from everywhere
through airports every day you can't
lose it or leave it in your car you
can't leave it in your hotel room like a
baby in georgia yeah you have to carry
it
they're heavy you're responsible for it
and they're heavy and they're heavy
yeah i just didn't know what the heck i
was really doing nobody told me
like really how to wrestle how to do
anything like i'd just show up and
they'd say okay you could
sometimes they'd hand you like literally
pages of dialogue
like i'm supposed to memorize this like
this is more
it's way harder than people think like
cutting a promo
all that kind of stuff and a lot of it's
has to do with
the thing people say that it's not real
or something because
when people cut good promos they're real
like you have to find a place inside
yourself that you
feel this you can convey that you're
angry at this person and you
do the things that you do in an acting
set where you're like when
you have to do something emotional where
you kind of go through in your head all
of these
really painful times in your lives and
you get to a place where
those emotions are like kind of right
there and you have to do that with
wrestling too
you know you have to make wrestling real
for you for
what you're doing for what you're
conveying like that's where wrestling is
entirely real and and then there's the
level of like
people's personal lives what's going on
how they feel about you
or how they feel about their own lives i
mean a lot of people are
when you're real pro you can separate
stuff like that but
some people coming up don't some people
get overly excited you know and
and then me being a beginner it's mostly
me that's getting like
you know ahead of things or like you
know not
you know you've learned in wrestling to
really slow down time
just kind of like you know allow
moments to happen and like get hit and
like really react to it
and look at an uh you know a fan
and just make a connection right there
it's like he's not going to do this to
me you know
you just make it real and then it
becomes real when you can
make wrestling really feel and and you
the audience
you can capture them and then they're
they're they're like
like while the match is going like oh
you almost made it and then you got them
on the hook you know and then you just
have to kind of reel them in
best way to reel them is like do a few
like
things that they don't either don't see
coming or a quick turnaround and then
boom you know some big thing that makes
them cheer and then
you know you either get them to uh
like the three count or or you kick out
yeah but it you should always end on
sort of your biggest
pop of the of the performance it sounded
like he was describing stand up
no [ __ ] i think stuff like
i'm sorry no no no no that was it
there's like that's a really good point
i was trying to think of some
of correlation and oddly i couldn't even
think of that yeah
but yeah i guess and you're taking me
back now too also to just being a fan i
remember
man when the guy would crawl over and
get on top of the other guy and
finally it's like good is gonna beat
evil and everything is gonna be okay in
the world and the
and then you're like this ref has like a
rotator cuff injury and he can barely
get his arm to go down
and he gets stalled at the top and some
other ref has to come in and push his
arm down
but it's just like life it's like things
just sometimes get so close
and then there's just these chops and
these ups and downs and
oh man yeah that's when it's beautiful
that's when that's not fake man yeah and
when you typically work with
veterans they know how to construct
matches where it's like
half the time i didn't even know like
what was going on like why are they
putting that here i don't understand
why would i but then you see it all
together and you start figuring out
and then once you get used to it then
you then you can relax into stuff
and you know certain things are coming
certain parts of the match
you know the heat and all the sort of
stuff that comes how you
construct a match listen up all you
business owners and all you
entrepreneurs i got to tell you about
this
so recently if you go to theovonne.com
you'll see
um work has been done to the site
construction
you know liveliness activity up
gradients
and i'm talking about modify that's
right
modify is a company that rivals any
other option on the market
for subscription based professional web
design services modify's
unbeatable new plan is fast affordable
and high quality they make a site that
can do what you need
do you need something done can your site
do it
now it can that's modify their plan
includes updates
unlimited support easy editing tools
and future redesigns
that's right there's no cost to build
and there's no contract and modify does
it all for you
no cost to build no contract and they do
it all for you
only two hundred and forty nine dollars
a month
work with professional designers to
create the last website
you'll ever need it's modifies the last
website ever plan
get yours today for 249 a month go to
modify.com t-h-e-o
that's my name that's modify with a
p-h-m-o-d-i-p-h-y
com theo man they get it done man if you
need it done
[ __ ] they get it done today we're
supporting a small
business you know that mom and pop or
sometimes that
sun and pop style of business and that's
what we got going on here
it's that award-winning jambalaya mix
and that garlic butter seasoning that's
right it's hot rods
creole hot rods creole
is a family-owned father-son duo
from louisiana and they're chasing their
food
dreams together a lot of people think
cajun food is always super
super spicy but it's not true the
ingredients we have put together will
stimulate don't taste buds without
making those eyeballs sweat
they have seven products available and
more continuing
to come out get that little daddy box
three seasons barbecue sauce
two packs of yamalaia and a koozai baby
or get that big daddy box it's like the
little daddy
but more thanks for listening to the
podcast
all purchasers get 10 off the code using
theo von go to hot rods creole dot com
that's h-o-t-r-o-d-s c-r-e-o-l-e
dot and use code theo
vaughn thank you very much
what is that net the the the leg twist
that neck what is that move is that you
is that your finishing moment oh the one
of your moves
yeah it's a legs i don't know it's it's
called a her karana some people call it
but yeah
that's one of my moves that's a move
that goes into a lot of stuff it's a
it's a frankensteiner if you're on the
corner of you know the top rope
or um there's a few a lot of different
moves go into it but my finishing moves
uh a diamond cutter like diamond dallas
page
now the because yeah because people
wouldn't say that uh ballet is fake
people wouldn't say that
a move i mean i guess
yeah there's just there's almost a greek
art to it or something
absolutely there is it really is good
against evil
i mean that's what's happening like in
the world right now it it really is
becoming a wrestling match
ah you know we've got heels and faces
good guys and bad guys
everybody i mean everything has turned
we've been saying this for years that
ever it's all turning into the wwe
yeah everybody's cutting promos it's
just like what is going on
no it's crazy everybody's cutting promos
everybody's driving for uber
it's just getting insane no
remember like when politicians they used
to be like in a place somewhere like
debating against each other now they're
all just cutting promos on [ __ ]
twitter
i know the whole feuds on twitter thing
is just crazy
and like everyone in
politics and everything are just a bunch
of wrestlers
going nuts it's everything man i
remember one of the most beautiful
things i ever saw though i was at the
i was at the wrestling and they had a
mexican gentleman a man
i think he was a man him and his son
were the same exact height
so who knows how old either one of them
was you know but
they were both wearing a championship
belt and when the rock came back it was
the night that the rock came back this
is about eight years ago i think or
maybe and when he came back they both
started bawling and crying together like
just
standing there i loved him and it was
just man it was
that's real the night was great but that
was probably the best thing that i saw
yeah i love that that's that's the best
part
just that humanity and the love for and
it's
it's because he took his son but his dad
probably took him and then you know his
dad probably took his father you know
that's what it is it's like
some of these moments are just part of
our history
yeah that's what upset me so much like i
i love wrestling i didn't want to be
excluded from it or go with my wife and
then have people like
yelling at me i was just sick of it
so i wanted to do something about it so
also like
everybody's got that feeling of like
something they dream of doing
you know we all wanted to tap into all
that like
you know not letting people bully you
like you know
going after your dreams like never
giving up like
giving something everything you got and
we didn't know where it would go
if it would you know if it would go to
one of the bigger places or something
but it worked out that it was this
perfect kind of full circle moment
you mean this documentary yeah with the
nasty boys just kind of like
getting my back and accepting me as one
of the guys
yeah yeah because it's interesting
because i didn't even know today
whenever
we're coming in here um i didn't i
didn't know
i didn't know if i should ask you in
advance like how serious is this
is this like uh you know just a
i don't want to say a spoof but no it's
it it definitely gives it more depth
to me uh knowing how you feel about it
you know
yeah and also one thing that's really
cool is that you got to be you've gotten
to be a hollywood star i mean you've
gotten to
the fruits of that stardom are really
i mean it's it's sketchy
and i don't even know if there's that
big if there's that big of stardom these
days
there's a few people but the
the idea of like like stardom forever is
very
hard to have i feel like um yeah
yeah like at a level of like you know
sometimes we think about it
guys yeah i mean there's like eight or
ten got you know it's so
they're really selective i mean they
have the not the luxury but they have
the patience to be
like able and uh just have it in
themselves
to really wait for the right project you
know get the right directors and
producers attached
make sure that that's the character that
they want to play but they also have the
luxury of maybe not working for a year
or two
right like i always i grew up with a
father was a working character actor who
so i think it like got into me that it's
like i'm a working actor like i need to
work so
yeah i'll do things that you know
you know on paper people say like why
are you doing this kids show
you know just for for whatever reason
but
it's it's all directly connected to just
working having a job going and doing
work like i'm not
comfortable sitting around all the time
yeah i think you have to give up but you
also it feels like you have to give up
some of you have to give up some of what
you want
in hollywood it seems like at certain
points you know like
like i got offered some things in the
past year and
there was this animated project i got
offered to be on this show called
hoops that just came out on netflix and
it just didn't
i kind of wanted to do my own animation
thing and i didn't
and i just wasn't sure and so you know i
had to say
that it wasn't for me even though it
would have been probably fun and neat
and i had to see it come out and be a
little disappointed
but then i also just had to remember
myself because i'll just
immediately start feeling bad like oh
man i wasn't in it and yeah yeah but i
don't
my brain doesn't want to remember nine
months ago when i was like i just don't
think i tried to make a choice for
myself
you know it's hard to do those choices
it's hard i'm like
to my detriment a few times like not
wanting to do something that turned out
to be really
great and really really great group
of people doing it sorry i'm burping
over here it's okay
um these mics don't pick that up but
that's diet soda man i remember when i
would see people drink diet sodas when i
was young i thought they were old that's
what starts to scare me dude
i'm no man i'm much older than you so
it's like
it's really funny when you start looking
back it's real like
real it's real yeah
how crazy is how much older you get once
you hit like 39 or 40.
yeah there's there's that 39 to 40
39 to 50 is like a whole thing
there are really cool things that happen
to you start like
not caring nearly as much about stuff oh
that's nice
yeah it's really nice not getting like
you start realizing where your anger
comes from
like it's like oh you start feeling you
can control it more
uh-huh and it's not like
crippling like sometimes it feels like
oh yeah man
i would like to have that less stress
dude i used to get especially over women
bro
here's the crazy thing if you want to
date a girl now and say she's younger
than you
it's so hard because you can't talk
about any music
oh yeah you say like oh do you listen to
it a second you get halfway through that
sense you're like [ __ ]
if i name a band that is like 15 years
old right now i'm gonna sound so [ __ ]
old
i know i don't know that whole that old
world is
yeah you like the black crows and you're
like oh i don't you know
i don't know like what are they at the
san diego zoo and you're like
i don't know she's like are they
endangered it's just
it's so sketchy bro trying to like
trying to keep up with the joneses of
youth is impossible
yeah it is it gets real sketchy
and it also is like i don't know you can
meet the right people but
you know it's a lot of the time just
pretty empty feeling
you know what i equate a lot of that
stuff too it's funny everyone's doing
zooms now and at the end of a zoom call
it's always like oh let's get to leave
the meeting thing
it's always like it's almost like you're
done [ __ ] and you're like oh
this feeling is like here's my real
face that's a good point here's my real
face
and no one can ever find it it's like
all right i love you
and then it's just well i have those
moments i've learned how to sit in them
a little more
the uncomfortable moms i did a show
called carter but it came out apparently
with
jerry o'connell who's a real i love
jerry man yeah
he's so talented dude he's hilarious
he's the best stories bro
he has the best stories he's just such a
funny guy
we had a blast we were just joking the
whole time but i went up to
canada to do a show carter and then uh
he was like something happened on the
set and people were getting a little
upset and he's like oh yeah yeah yeah
i was like i was licked and i was like
what's up it's like
i think they're getting a little
argument or something i was like yeah
they're in an argument why are you
getting all jacked up about it
you just love the fact that there was
conflict
and i was like oh wow that's such a like
an interesting response because my
past response just from being from a kid
from a chaotic
like childhood or whatever i'd get like
super like
like uh i don't know embarrassed or
something or like
yeah i'd be i'll feel like oh you know
why are they fighting of that whole
thing and i it's like such a kid
response to it
yeah and now when you're able to kind of
like not take it personally
or it doesn't involve you and you know
you're having a conflict you know you
don't have to solve it
yeah and you can kind of sit back and i
can see how i don't know if i could ever
enjoy it
but i could see how he could be relaxed
about it jerry's making it has he's
eating popcorn as you look over he's
[ __ ] loving it
dude he's so talented man he has this
story about growing up
in he grew up in new york during the
aids epidemic or pandemic and he has
this wild story about how
half of the people in his building when
he was a kid died
and just how like every couple of weeks
he'd come home and another neighbor
would have died and just um
man it's just fascinating and he's such
a gripping when you
you know why he's a good actor because
when you were talking to him it is like
you are
in just an elevator into like another
like a elevator that goes forward right
into his damn soul yeah
he's one of a kind dude that's fun man
yeah when i was
uh yeah there he is right there with a
guy with brendan shaw right there
and he's a guy
but uh dude it's so funny when i was
young i used to feel so much like i'm
responsible for everything like no
matter like
i would feel so much shame like i feel
so ashamed of everything that happened
like if
like one of my family members did
something and they was off or something
i would feel like it always like
reflected on me like
every yeah i was just ashamed of
everything man i know
that's a sucks yeah it super sucks i
used to have this
thing where i've i like discovered i was
kind of a shame
addict i was like addicted to the
feeling of like putting myself in a
position where it was
like either shameful or like and i
didn't
want to but i kept putting like calling
into howard stern and then having to
like
apologize to people or even maybe like
what i just did with
talking about alyssa or whatever just
not meaning to but it might be
something in me that why do i talk about
somebody else you know what i mean i
don't know what it is
is she gonna get mad i don't know not
that i did it for any reason but i don't
know why
my brain would do it sometimes right
where i'd get into this thing just
to be humiliated or something which is a
terrible thing to do
it's like really painful place to be
but dude sometimes it's so funny i would
love like uh
i remember one time inviting i had two
girlfriends right and a
huge rarity in my life and i invited
them both to a bar
right oh my gosh and i knew it was gonna
make me feel
i some people would think oh this can be
fun cat fight these girls gonna go at it
i just knew in hindsight looking back
i'm gonna feel so [ __ ] bad because
i care about both these girls both of
them care about me and bo
everybody's going to get their heart
broken right now and i was just like
let's do it
yeah and i know that feeling but looking
back like yeah it's like man
yeah i wonder if there's ways where my
brain leads me into places to
really feel not great about stuff you
know
without just because of old patterns
yeah i do things to blow [ __ ] up a lot
like that thing sounds kind of like that
or you do something like with the
specific intention of just
blowing all the [ __ ] [ __ ] just to
like
[ __ ] it you know go punk rock there's
always been a little bit of a punk rock
vibe
i do that with work sometimes man even
work stuff yeah you know like
uh because i've found in the past two
years like i like to i don't
i really didn't like in some ways
working with others in some ways i
didn't realize it
i've just always kind of done things by
myself and so i didn't realize until
i had to start to work with others a
little more that i have to
i don't know it's not a reflection of me
it's just a group thing and but man i
would
i had such a just a visceral reaction to
it man
that's what i would you know i'd always
i don't know i'd get up in the middle of
the night and [ __ ]
rattle off an email that's like oh this
is like a bomb yeah yeah so that
three hours later when everybody wakes
up i know
i did that stuff too oh oh god
it's painful you like kind of a lot of
the time
and especially sometimes you're working
with the kind of people that do it
where they create issues and like
problems where there are none
just to like have a problem yeah and
then you have to deal with the problem
i don't know yeah i'm like the david
blaine of complete [ __ ] [ __ ]
like guess what tada [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know
um thanks did you ever have it
that was great
did you ever um could you talk a little
bit about addiction and think do you
talk about that kind of stuff
yeah i mean i've had my battles with it
so i've been like on this roller coaster
yeah it's a tough ride kind of it's a
really tough ride
but it's a fun ride though too i think
it is i mean
it's fun when you learn like i don't
know how not to do it
i mean it's just beating yourself up my
addict's just like
literally like in my wife asking me do
you just want to kill yourself it's like
no but there's something inside me
that's trying to
kill me absolutely has no problem with
it
you know what i mean so you have to like
but then also like
just not wanting to go there like right
my personal life like
like i i don't know i uh
i i like when i first sort of fell off
the rails
it was kind of public i was like calling
an hour shirt and all this [ __ ]
and i don't remember any of that i don't
know i don't even know about it oh thank
god yeah
oh yeah it's just like completely like
like
regurgitating my life you know and just
like oh yeah but we do that here yeah we
do
yeah you do that but it's your own place
and it's right it's like you know you're
also not
[ __ ] up doing it oh yeah yeah i would
do that
dude i had a nightmare so i ended up on
uh
opie and jim norton they used to have a
show yeah opie and uh
this was after opie and anthony and
serious it was across from howard and a
lot of times people would do the loop up
there and they'd run it
so i ended up one night all cocaine all
night driving a taxi the taxi drivers in
the back he's in the taxi right wow
long night dude great time yeah um
get to the radio station i would be on
air at 6 00 a.m bro can't even
i mean can't even feel my [ __ ] face
bro with either hand
i tried both hands right at first i
thought oh something's wrong with this
hand you know
and then i tried feeling my face with
this hand and i knew something wrong
with my face
and uh daryl strawberry's the other
guest oh my gosh
and he's a good he could help you
through it
yeah if anybody can help me through it
but man
put it behind your ear you'll get your
feeling back
there i am right there almost blasted
out of my brain
oh my gosh dude i had done enough
cocaine to freaking
take daryl strawberry to extra innings
bro no doubt no
kidding i see you grinding away too oh
man i lost a half inch in my mouth that
day oh no
it's such a big cocaine's little burst
yeah
the worst really is just i say it turns
men into mice
yeah and it's fun though that's the
thing they put a little bit of fun in it
yeah i mean it's fun it's just so rapid
the fun
yeah it's all so full like hot air yeah
they need so many to do it but it just
takes
much a lot more work you know you just
have to work to get
those highs but it just takes the work
to get there and then it's like
the culmination of all the work and then
you have that fun
time and then even the process of doing
this stuff can be fun
too yeah where you can get that life
high yeah yeah
yeah no there's definitely a lot i mean
there's things i like now about
definitely
waking up and being able to handle my
day oh hell yeah and like open my eyes
up have those little moments i'm sure it
is with family and stuff too especially
yeah and the more responsibilities i get
my in my life the less
i find myself wanting to do stuff like
that you know yeah
um but so with the so are you
with the documentary i don't know if i
didn't watch in because i just don't
know how much like you want to share
about like give it
are you making a push now to get more
to get more into wrestling yeah i don't
know i
might wrestle more i did it mainly for
this documentary
so i kind of did what i set out to do
right if we wrestle some more i mean i
love the world
you know uh i like wrestling with rjcity
as my tag team partner
so i don't know if i want to do it
without like a tag team partner
it's a i always got in trouble without a
tag team partner
yeah yeah unless it was with the pro
like colt cabana or something
and here's a guy right here he's
probably alone what
theo what's up david seth from kentucky
here and my question for david is
who has more fun in the wrestling
community heels or faces
you know do you get to have more fun
being that bad guy or do you have more
fun being the face of it all
game game gang bro
that's a good question yeah it is a good
question the heels definitely have more
fun within it
like it's just you know heels represent
like
being chicken shits being like
backstabbers having no
spine you can just say the worst things
you could just do all this stuff you can
just when you come from a place like
that
it's weird when people get mixed up like
some people get mixed up like they might
be the heel but they want to be tough in
the match
too and it doesn't work as well if
you're
like if the audience gets more invested
if you cheat
to like hurt them or you do something
like something like if you do a heel
behavior
yeah if you're gonna be a heel be a heel
yeah yeah exactly
so yeah and then really be a heel so
much so it's like
being chicken about stuff or cheating to
win or like
all that kind of stuff it happens a lot
man
it's really just a reflection of life
you know it's just such a
it's such a like whatever i think it's
called a greek play or something where
they do plays and it's
you know in greece or something and they
you know it's like good and evil
you know it's just like that man yeah
for sure
but i would love to see you beat the
[ __ ] out of uh mystic rick though
yeah yeah dude do you guys have a little
uh like a little like promotion or
something
is it does he have a belt the uh theo
called him out and he never responded
rat king called him out and he never
responded man we had a belt that started
years ago
uh when they have a podcast called the
fighter and the kid
yeah and they had a vote on their
podcast for
best guest or one of the best guests in
the year and that guy got a belt
so once the belt came into it it came
that's the origin story of the belt
and then you know we started taking on
different characters and you know just
you know kind of like most of our fan
base is really a bunch of rats you know
not bad rats but just like
underdogs you know yeah right there with
you yeah cheese hunters you know
so yeah i feel it um
what else do you want to talk about you
think i don't know
did you ever do any jail time no i've
never
had a mug shot i've been pretty careful
about certain things
i've been wild but did you ever like
wreck a car
really really no i never drove always i
mean i've
driven once in a while but i avoided it
all very
yeah yeah that's one of the main things
that's really good then yeah yeah i
never wanted to
get a situation where i hurt anybody
yeah do you think um do you think that
um
[Music]
yeah i just wonder if i could handle one
of those prisons or not you know you
think you'd be good in prison
i don't know man i would i hate to have
to
have to deal with it but you know we did
a
documentary called survivor's guide to
prison
which was really cool we produced it
with danny trejo it was a
matthew cook film it was really great my
wife really produced it but
uh that taught us a lot about the prison
system
you know you know how corrupt it is and
how it needs to be changed but actually
being in there that would be something
else i mean i
i taught a acting class at san quentin a
couple of times
yeah yeah so good actors in there it was
cool it was
it was weird i had them do this
improvisational game called
animal transformation where you pick an
animal and then you transform it
into like all right let's put you know
you're a giraffe and you're
a run run right now rhinoceros
yeah yeah i was about to say
ryan reynolds
but you bring them up to like human form
but still maintain the characteristics
so like this dude would be a
you know like a rhino or whatever and
there's
goes up to the giraffe but it was like
kind of aggressive because
rhinos seem aggressive and then the the
guard was like stop stop stop you gotta
stop
and he explained to me like they could
get into this little acting thing right
here
but then they could go out and like get
in a huge fight on the yard
if if like someone disrespects each
other and there's like all this
code and all this stuff so i'd hate to
have to learn that stuff but
you know i get by but do you think when
you think about prison like do you think
what parts of prison do you think you
would enjoy
i don't know man like you like a small
room i like a small room
i like characters so i'm sure there'd be
some characters in there that i
gonna hit i like the kind of joking that
happens
in places like that or in school or in
like you know places where people are
all hanging out and kind of not bored
but
uh have time on their hands or it's just
like hanging out with your homies like
yeah
you know when you're growing up the guys
you grew up with the way you can joke
with them is like
you know a great feeling yeah why do we
lose that as we get older it just
i mean that disappears doesn't it in a
lot of ways it does
you have to kind of stick with those
guys you have you when you go back home
you probably have friends like that
right
yeah yeah i'm on a couple text chains
like that but
you never can really replicate that just
that
childhoodness of it where somebody
doesn't have to
now people have responsibilities and
somebody you know
yeah they owe somebody money or there's
some [ __ ] or something
yeah totally but
i love brody that's
yeah man one of a kind he just had a
birthday the other one did he really
yeah he's awesome i knew him for a while
we hired him on a
show called uh midnightly news to
warm up the audience like back in
[ __ ] back in the 90s or something did
you uh yeah he uh
one thing that i loved about him was
his i think he just always had this
ability like
to make you feel kind of he was such a
loner almost he was such like a scared
dude
but he always would like really kind of
go out of his way to kind of make you
feel included you know
um he man talk about
being a loving person but finding it
really hard i feel like to express how
your love in like normal ways and stuff
yeah
he was a warrior man i can't i still
cannot believe that it that
suicide it's just crazy how it just i
mean it sneaks in
yeah like in an instant almost yeah it's
sad and people can't do it anymore
yeah but i also get it sometimes man i
get it but there's
like you have to fight through these the
hard times because there is beauty on
the other side
yeah this is a really dark time right
now just in general
a lot of people are scared a lot of
people are losing
loved ones and you don't know where
there's
you know other bills are going to get
paid from so it's really scary at this
time but you have to know that it
we will make it through this yeah and we
will have
your fun on the other side and there's
little things that come like as you get
older that are really beautiful
little things and it's just literally
like
catching you know tadpoles with your
kids or like
the wind on your hair like you know you
get an appreciation for
certain things getting a snack anything
something small
i know when you can really like sit
there like oh this grape tastes great
like yeah you're like in a place where
you're like you're taking a moment to
appreciate
a grape yeah it's like oh this is
different because you're not like as
wound up about the world yeah man it's
tough dude i made a gratitude list this
morning i'm trying to
get back more into gratitude you know
just be thankful for the little things
that's the best man
that's such a key it gets so tricky um
yeah i think so yeah i i feel like so
yeah after watching the doc i felt like
it was it's really kind of a
i guess it really does kind of stand as
a story of like setting a goal
and kind of um do you feel like it's
getting a monkey off your back
a little bit i mean it definitely you
know what the the
thing i learned was that it was me like
i had this one therapy session with my
therapist and and i was like
talking about my mom and dad and how
heavy like their marriage and
relationship was and then i was like
wait they're both dead it's like
literally this heaviness is just inside
me
and they're gone so like to work to lift
that was really
helpful you're like david duchovny but i
feel like the x-files are on the inside
i'm telling you it is we all have to
figure out all this stuff going on
inside
it's so crazy bro how much crazy baggage
we carry man i know man
yeah and then i will swim in it i will
make a [ __ ]
swimming pool out of my baggage and then
dive right into it i know when there's
tons of other things to go do
people like hey come get on this water
slide come get on this ferris wheel like
i just made this amazing swimming pool
with all my own [ __ ]
yeah let's just go in there for a while
oh it gets to me after a while what else
we got nick we had a written question
that came in it said when will we see
chuck hank in the san diego twins you're
telling me there's a movie i did like
eight years ago
and it still hasn't come out i just have
no idea it was
i was so impressed by this group of
filmmakers because they all had cameras
they're all shooting i was like
you have like eight cameras like nobody
has eight cameras unless you're doing a
sitcom
and then uh so they're shooting and
they're like having all these angles
they're all filmmakers they're all
editors and then the movie disappears
for
years there's rumor that it's still
going to be done but i just don't what
cause
what causes that kind of stuff when
something disappears what caused that
could have been any
kind of thing it's usually like there's
a falling out between the filmmakers and
then one person's either in charge of it
and then just doesn't
like complete it or there's
just tied up so they're sort of push
pulling
i don't know there's all kinds of things
yeah
what about you what are you interested
in doing like uh
thinking about getting uh i'm thinking
about getting a dang dog recently
yeah man that's a real that's a
beautiful thing have you had one before
oh no kidding like do you know what kind
of dog you've been looking for
i think like a one like uh everybody's
kind of has like a labradoodle right now
yeah so i've been thinking about that
kind of i feel like they have nice like
kind of eyebrows kind of but
yeah but you need a bigger dog for any
reason
i don't really i was thinking also a
black lab then also a friend of mine has
a
dachshund wiener dog yeah and man he was
nice
yeah dogs are the differences big dogs
are dope because they're big dogs and
like they're
i don't know but little dogs are amazing
too i've had both
little dogs are just fun because for
someone like you you can almost bring
them anywhere yeah like
and then you become the guy with the dog
but that's the whole thing
but if you love this dog and he's really
easy and he can be here
and like it'd probably be like fun for
you
yeah bigger dogs are harder to to bring
like they're harder to bring on trips
they're just harder to
to manage but they're incredible i don't
we have four
basset hounds which is oh they're big
that's like a rich old looking dog
they're big dogs they're like
medium-sized dogs but they got little
dog legs so they're
really short to the ground oh bassett
hounds have the long with the long ears
yeah
yeah yeah yeah those are fun dogs oh
yeah they're good southern dogs too
yeah i wouldn't mind i'm trying to think
of maybe what to get i don't know
i went to i went to a man's house
yesterday and he had two bunnies too
oh no yeah that's cool but that's your
big responsibility is that what you're
kind of like
yeah i'm thinking about that you know
now there you go right there that's
beautiful yeah oh and look at that
undercarriage huh they got some real
meat on them
yeah they have rolls of skin when
they're when they're like
but they're pretty well behaved yeah i
mean someone like
they're all individuals so some of them
are better behaved than others i mean
they all have their own personalities
but you know they howl and bark a lot
these guys so some of them don't as much
but
that's just something to think about if
you're you have to leave them in your
apartment or house for a little while
sometimes
the barking can be a whole thing or like
get babysitters
yeah that's what i would think maybe
getting a friend with a yard or
something yeah
um but yeah what else i don't know i
want to take some brazilian jiu jitsu
actually
yeah man that's amazing do you have a
guy uh i don't have a guy
but we have a guy eddie bravo that
trains people oh you did oh that's tough
he's dope but we don't know but i i
don't know i trained with higan machado
during this whole thing
oh he's amazing bro so you've taken it
yeah you enjoyed it just
not like uh right belts or anything but
just for
exercising hell yes it's important to
learn that [ __ ]
yeah that's what i want to learn just i
think like kind of working on that
confidence that inner confidence of just
you know
feeling a little more comfortable yes
that's what any of that stuff will do
for you like i i
i it's funny that i got a brown belt in
yoshikai karate but
uh it was i never got a black belt i had
like one more
thing that my sensei moved to
florida i'm like stuck with the brown
belt but it's kind of perfect
it's kind of it's got a good colored
belt but uh
what it does teach you like once you get
into it and you're like training a lot
and doing it as an exercise and stuff
like your balance and everything you're
like
you learn all this kind of like little
ancient tricks with life that are just
like really kind of cool when you
learn all the like katas and all the
stuff it'll just prepare you for kind of
stuff like that and then jiu-jitsu is a
whole other beast which is amazing
it's so [ __ ] cool yeah it seems cool
i just always have this dream like i'm
somewhere you know i'm at a subway or
something i didn't want to go but
somebody took me
you know because i don't like it but
and then somebody like some guy's like
hey you know what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you
you know and i'll be like that you know
and then
next thing you know i have to [ __ ]
defend myself dude
first of all i don't really probably
want to be in a fight second of all i do
not want to fight in a
subway bro you know what i'm saying like
at least beat my ass out of five guys
you know
so but i want to be able to at least
like
know that if something happens like i
don't have to feel like i don't have a
chance
you know yeah that's i feel like that
when i was young that's always the
feeling that i had man
every kid was like tougher than me i
felt like so i know that feeling
i was like i don't have a chance dude
i'm gonna go hide in this tree or i'll
do something [ __ ] gig
make a kite or something like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with this kid you know
yeah nowadays you have to be careful
fighting just because some people
like a lot of people do know that kind
of stuff and oh yeah everything going on
someone henry
you know if you saw henry hudo somewhere
regularly
you'd beat him with a stick probably
it'll candy come out bring him a picture
of him
but he is a legend you know
yeah i mean he's you know
is he undefeated uh no he lost to
demetrius once
and then he i think that might be his
only loss he beat
demetrius the second time but even you
can just get a picture of him nick
that's him right there i was trying to
get him like one where he's not or how
tall he is
i mean i think he's five two oh yeah
but he's the ch i mean he won three
belts i think oh man that's tough
that's though yeah there he is compared
to some other guys
some whites no kidding yeah that's
actually the big shell big show zones
he's seven feet something have you ever
been slammed by any of those real big
guys
um you bully ray slammed me through the
table
hell yeah put my hips out
yeah i did that's what my back like what
would happen with me it's like either my
neck or my back would go out
constantly so then i'd just be jacked up
for the next
week or so it just sucks oh it's so
brutal and would you get those shots
would you get some shots to help it
no i wish like they probably have that
stuff at wwe but then the independent
circuit they don't even have like
ambulances hopefully we'll have like a
first aid kit well yeah on the
independent circuit man i remember
growing up they had some dude's bus
fighting man it would be people in their
backyard and this before
people wouldn't even videotape it people
would draw a picture of it and show it
the next day
you know this is back hard wrestling man
and uh people would just put a bunch of
picnic table i mean it was choppy
it was just extremely dangerous too but
yeah you know people's stepdads and
family disputes
one man threw another man into a damn
ditch fire bus one time
pretty cool man oh yeah fire's intense
um what else we got nick i had a
question about like the independent
wrestling circus
is it still like kind of the wild wild
west with like some of the performance
enhancers because i watched ready to
rumble last night
just because of this and uh uh mr
perfect
kurt henning uh macho man
and then i don't think mean gene was on
anything but all three of those guys
have passed away
and it's like it seems like there's not
wrestlers that get over like 60 or
whatever and
you keep hearing about dying or is it
still like kind of that unhealthy
well obviously it's bad for your body
too but like i feel like the steroids
back in the day definitely played a part
for sure i don't know like
how many like how prevalent steroids are
i think when john cena came up it was
like real
like from that point on there was real
more of a focus on body and like
strength training and working out also
some of the guys
kind of the stature guys kind of fell
down so it's not as like big
giant but there's a few guys that are
really super buff and i don't know if
they
take anything or not i never did i had
to
i just i always liked the kind of body
that like a bruce lee has
where it's more ripped than anything you
know what i mean if you can lose enough
weight
you got muscles under there so once you
lose the fat it kind of looks bigger
anyway
yeah and then you learn little things
like
you know eating protein right you know
right after you
within the first half hour of doing
weight helps a lot to build muscle
but yeah he's like the baddest
and he's not like huge but he's did you
ever meet him
no he never got to me yeah but we were
huge fans growing up
and i met his daughter who was really
nice really was she hot
yeah she's beautiful she's just sweet
and just
yeah bruce lee beautiful she was just
like has like a cool like air
to her and you could tell you got to be
can you imagine being bruce lee's
daughter and you're just [ __ ]
you know a dick then it happens i mean
there's some people that just get caught
up with this
whole world i know i know i bet
especially in the world that you've seen
man really being into hollywood it gets
really
kind of vapid out there yeah it does
i mean there's a lot of [ __ ] that
happens i've been in the business 30
years so
that's crazy man yeah i mean how old are
you i'm 40 years old oh you are
yeah you seem so young so i'm getting
older man i'm an adult now and
40s are cool it's a cool age so it's
when stuff starts not
you'll get you figure your world out
yeah
i like the idea of stuff not having
being so stressed like
you know not being so serious yeah
i do too i think that battle always
that'll go on forever i mean especially
just
dogs and kids and all that stuff if you
want to have them
there's just there's a lot of [ __ ] that
comes with them but then there's also
like the most silliest stuff you'll ever
do you know what i mean which is then
becomes the funnest stuff you'll ever
experience
yeah when you look back on on being a
chat on being a wrestling champion do
you
look back on it fondly yeah i mean i
just to be part of this world the world
that i always loved i look at that
fondly
you know you know and without like
griping about stuff
you know it's wrestling so i use it all
in the
movie you know what i mean i mean i'm a
fan of
andy kaufman's that's part of this whole
thing you know what i mean it's just
part of
what i the things that i love right now
so it's like
i i do look at it fondly i mean
especially with sort of coming back and
and like who knows if this is the end of
it
you know who knows if there'll be some
other kind of wrestling adventures
yeah what do you see do you are there
other i mean do you still have a lot of
stuff obviously
you want to get into stuff that you can
make more that's your own um
do you feel like yourself getting more
motivated towards that kind of
yeah for sure i mean that's what i do
with my spare time in between waiting
for something or auditioning for
something
just sort of uh yeah work on projects
that i believe in
and have you done any movies in space
man i could really see you in space
i would love that i mean how cool how
cool would it be to be like the first
film
shot in space that would be the baddest
that was a little better yeah i think it
would be i mean i i don't know space we
keep going to see
shitholes man mars the moon like he's
playing like look i'm no [ __ ]
i'm no real estate agent well i don't
know why the moon they don't
already have like a disney world up
there i know nobody would like it to be
upsetting
yeah some people but i think it'd be
amazing oh i think something small you
could stop in at least a rest area
you know but yeah it seems like we keep
going to these shitholes bro
mars let's be honest bro this place is a
[ __ ]
i'm not a real estate agent but every
picture you see is like this place is
garbage dude fire everywhere there's no
place you could even [ __ ]
you can't even you couldn't even have an
outdoors it's just
i don't know palm springs yeah yeah it's
like
they can build it up it's like palm
springs dirty grandfather
yeah you know it's just like why don't
we let's find a decent planet
or quit [ __ ] around man you know
spend the money send a shuttle in the
[ __ ]
zaire and let's [ __ ] habitate over
there you know like i just feel like if
we need to work more locally look at
this
come here come on dude oh yeah
and you got dumb chicks and dudes
and chews out there sitting around
saying oh man i think we'll ever live on
mars like idiots at a [ __ ] bar
somewhere you know you got one third of
the bw
buffalo wild wings population sitting
there four beers deep
man wonder if we'll ever live on mars
you know
play's a [ __ ] man sorry i i just i
didn't know
oh marsley yeah i didn't know anybody
was going to be here when i felt like
this
but it's just kind of just making me mad
man
we just got bigger fish to fry dude but
i want to see some more of these promos
i want to see more of these wrestlers
cut promos i want to see
more politicians cut promos yeah dude
i'm telling you
one politician puts out a dope ass
wrestling promo i feel like it they
would get all the votes they would get a
lot of votes
i had one friend who was voting for
trump because he
he provided you know wrestlemania at his
casinos i was like you can't vote for
him for that reason though you just
can't
not for that reason dude it's crazy i
mean he
that the whole world is so crazy his
wife looked melania looks hot though
i gotta say that man yeah you know
people act like she's not hot like
yeah i'll pretend a lot of stuff but i'm
not gonna pretend that she's not
dude that's insane yeah i can imagine i
mean you have to have
people have to present you a lot of
times with projects where they're like
you would be perfect for this huh
was there a point where you didn't want
to really do some of that stuff
no not really i mean when you get hot
you get a
like a lot of offers so then it's like
you have to kind of sift through the
good stuff but when you're not you just
kind of like are trying to find
good projects to work on yeah so
typically
low budget things that you don't get
paid for you never know how they're
really going to turn out if they ever
come out
at all yeah yeah i've been offered a
couple of real wild animals man
but yeah i don't know man
we'll see you know yeah i would love to
do something where
you know a friend of mine a black friend
of mine said that black people and
aliens don't get along well
or there's beef there's so much space
there's a new there's or there's like
beef in that community
and so i'm like yeah that's amazing
so i'm like wondering how do we get
let's get that film
you know i'll be like some guy just like
you know some guy that works for the
united nations or whatever
but i'm just thinking how do we get to
see that
you know because i'm ready to see that
that's good you know how to get a
treatment
a outline than a script yeah brothers
versus aliens dude i'm ready to break it
there's no way i wouldn't watch that
that's amazing so
um all right well david i appreciate you
coming in man thanks for having me man
yeah big fan of your comedy and i
appreciate you
well i definitely remember like the day
that you said hey to me at the gym it
made me feel really good i'll i remember
uh
telling one of my friends like dude i
got to meet david arquette today it was
awesome
um but yeah i was happy to watch the
documentary man i'll watch the end now
that i know it's safe to
and and you guys love to check out
um you cannot kill david arquette
thank you so much and just stay alive i
guess right and we'll see a secret
that's it i'll i'll be alive i can't die
okay you can't kill me
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these
leaves i must be cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel it
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
on my
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
moving way too fast on the runaway train
with a heavy load of my
hands
and these rails that i've been riding on
they want so thin that they're
[Music]
now